Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Il y a peu de temps encore,
je me sentais frustré,
impuissant,
révolté,
lorsque chaque semaine,
je découvrais un nouveau
scandale économique -
l'exploitation des enfants
dans les mines de coltan,
les conditions désastreuses dans
le textile, le scandale des abattoirs,
la liste est longue -
avec une question :
« Mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire,
tout seul, pour changer cela ? »
Posons-nous d'abord cette question :
quelle est l'origine de ces scandales ?
Ce bus a une capacité de 62 places.
Si ce bus transportait les plus
riches personnes du monde,
il aurait le même poids financier
que la moitié de la population mondiale.
Qui veut ce type de monde ?
Aujourd'hui,
85% des bénéfices d'une multinationale
sont reversés aux actionnaires.
Autrement dit, c'est là-bas
que tout se décide : à la Bourse.
Les dirigeants, les employés,
les cadres, ne sont que des relais.
Ils sont les premiers
à subir les conséquences.
Nous le voyons au sein des entreprises
avec l'augmentation de ces syndromes
que vous connaissez peut-être tous :
le burn-out,
le bore-out - celui de l'épuisement
professionnel par l'ennui -
et le dernier, théorisé
par deux chercheurs,
qui concerne pas mal
de monde : le brown-out -
celui d'exécuter des tâches contraires
à son éthique personnelle.
Prenons du recul,
et posons-nous cette question :
et si ces entreprises étaient
devenues malades
et qu'elles avaient besoin de nous
pour retrouver un peu de sens ?
Les actionnaires sont des personnes
qui se focalisent uniquement, en partie,
sur la rentabilité
de leurs investissements.
Il y en a peut-être ce soir parmi nous.
Mais honnêtement, qui voudrait
que son investissement soit négatif ?
Absolument personne. C'est normal.
Le problème est que nous
ne parlons pas la même langue.
Selon une étude de l'Inserm,
en France, le chômage tue cinq fois plus
que les accidents de la route.
Les plans de licenciements,
les délocalisations,
le mal-être des employés,
l'accaparement des terres, des ressources,
ça ne leur parle pas aux actionnaires.
La réduction des coûts,
l'augmentation de la productivité,
le contrôle du flux d'approvisionnement,
c'est beaucoup plus clair, c'est concret.
L'éthique ne s'incarne dans rien
et à aucun moment
dans leur vision économique.
Sans éthique, tous
les ingrédients sont réunis
pour que le système dérive par nature.
C'est systémique.
Et c'est la logique de leur paradigme.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
Comment concrètement
peut-on guérir ce système ?
Tout d'abord, on sait que l'un
des indicateurs d'un système sain,
c'est la présence de contre-pouvoirs.
Normalement, les institutions,
l'État est là pour veiller à ça.
Mais savez-vous qu'il y a entre 15 000 et
30 000 lobbyistes, rien qu'à Bruxelles ?
Le simple écart entre ces chiffres
en dit long sur tout le chemin
qu'il nous reste à faire.
Les GAFA - Google, Apple,
Facebook, Amazon -
sont l'exemple même de cette
absence de contre-pouvoirs.
Souvent le monopole
d'un domaine d'activité
présente des risques.
Les régulateurs sont là pour ça,
victimes, eux aussi, des lobbys.
Mais, le système a une grosse faille.
Et savez-vous
quel est le caillou dans la chaussure
de ces grandes entreprises non éthiques ?
Dans une société de consommation,
il y a bien un acteur clé :
c'est nous, les consommateurs.
Nous sommes tous,
dans cette salle, consommateurs,
mais combien parmi nous
sont consom'acteurs ?
Anna Lappe dit : « À chaque fois
que vous dépensez de l'argent,
vous votez pour le type
de monde que vous voulez. »
Voilà notre pouvoir extraordinaire :
notre pouvoir d'achat,
celui d'acheter des biens
produits par une entreprise
qui partage mes valeurs, le « buy-cott »,
ou le pouvoir de refuser ses valeurs
et refuser ses produits, le boycott.
« Je suis ce que je consomme. »
C'est ça, être un consom'acteur.
En 2002, nous étions 24 % d'Européens
à acheter plus cher
pour acheter responsable.
Nous sommes le double, aujourd'hui,
et 66 % dans le monde.
Avoir une consommation
socialement responsable,
c'est prendre en compte les conséquences
publiques de sa consommation privée.
Souvent, quand je parle de boycott,
je donne cet effet.
Alors que l'Histoire nous montre
que le boycott, c'est avant tout :
Gandhi en 1930,
Martin Luther King en 1955,
Nelson Mandela en 1970.
Le boycott est une liberté d'expression,
un outil pacifique et efficace
du faible économiquement et politiquement,
mais du fort démographiquement,
l'outil parfait du peuple.
Accessible à tous,
même à l'indigné du canapé,
il a l'avantage de toucher les deux
piliers d'une société de consommation :
l'argent, qui est le nerf de l'entreprise,
et l'image, qui est le nerf de la marque.
On sait qu'une entreprise évolue
si le marché l'y oblige.
Créons cette obligation.
Créons ce déclic, cette prise de
conscience avec le boycott bienveillant.
Fabrice Épelboin a dit, lors
du précédent TEDxLyon :
« La révolution numérique va pousser
les marques à interagir avec les foules. »
Nous y sommes.
C'est dans ce contexte qu'est
née l'association i-boycott,
la première plateforme
de boycott bienveillant
qui donne un droit de réponse
à l'entreprise et l'invite à évoluer.
La seule manière de clôturer
une campagne de boycott
est de convaincre la majorité
des boycottants.
Ce sont les principes de la démocratie
qui sont appliqués au marché.
C'est la démocratie dans l'économie.
Les boycottants peuvent aussi proposer
des alternatives à la marque incriminée ;
c'est le volet « buycott ».
Les consommateurs, les consom'acteurs,
votent avec leur portefeuille.
Lancée en juin, la plateforme réunit
plus de 50 000 consom'acteurs,
plusieurs dialogues engagés avec
les multinationales, dont une victoire.
C'est la construction d'un dialogue
plus responsable, plus riche,
entre les consom'acteurs, d'un côté,
et les entreprises cachées
derrière la marque, de l'autre.
Nous sommes littéralement
dans un changement de paradigme,
parce que cela touche
l'ensemble des acteurs
et rééquilibre le jeu
dans le domaine économique.
Les entreprises peuvent,
pour la première fois,
quantifier l'éthique.
L'éthique devient un facteur
économique à prendre en compte.
Autrefois, nous disions aux actionnaires :
« Notre objectif, c'est 10 % -
voire 15 %, soyons fous ! »
mais tout le monde
trouvait ça génial, 15 % !
Demain, nous dirons
à ces mêmes actionnaires :
« Notre objectif est de 10 %,
en délocalisant - tiens, tiens ! -
mais cela implique des risques,
notamment de boycott qui peut
faire chuter notre rentabilité. »
Là, tout de suite,
on réfléchit à deux fois,
parce que l'éthique commence
à parler économiquement.
Les entreprises peuvent aussi
dialoguer avec les boycottants.
Sur le schéma que vous allez voir,
c'est le résultat des votes
des boycottants,
suite à la réponse des différentes
entreprises, souvent multinationales.
Donc on peut voir que Oasis a convaincu
88,8 % des boycottants.
Les consom'acteurs ne sont pas
dans une logique punitive.
Ils sont dans un dialogue.
C'est vraiment important.
Parlons-en des consom'acteurs.
Les consommateurs
ont enfin un levier pour agir
contre ces injustices économiques.
Ils ne sont plus seuls.
Loin du « cliquisme »,
c'est une action collective
individualisée.
Ils sont acteurs et déterminés,
comme le prouve cette image.
Cette image a été prise
par une consom'actrice,
suite à la campagne
de boycott contre Petit Navire.
Fidèle cliente depuis 35 ans,
elle renvoie ses produits.
Je vous demande de vous
mettre dans l'état d'esprit
de ce directeur de marketing
qui va recevoir ce colis.
Malgré les millions dans la publicité,
malgré les campagnes de promotion,
une consom'actrice
refuse de consommer
des produits déjà achetés
pour des raisons éthiques.
L'éthique commence à lui parler.
On voit qu'il y a un nouvel
acteur qui a émergé,
un acteur puissant,
un acteur qui sera l'allié de poids
pour toutes ces personnes
qui veulent apporter plus d'éthique
au sein même de leur entreprise,
ces agents du changement qui,
souvent, sont impuissants et démunis.
Le boycott va pousser les entreprises
à prioriser les filières éthiques
en s'appuyant sur ces personnes-là.
Nous allons créer des cellules
de guérison au sein des entreprises.
C'est un allié de poids aussi pour
les ONG qui travaillent sur le terrain,
qui sont dans un rapport de force,
sans cesse, avec les entreprises.
Lors d'une campagne de boycott,
l'entreprise doit convaincre des dizaines
de milliers de clients, de consommateurs.
On n'a pas de rapport
de force avec ses clients,
c'est contre-nature pour une entreprise.
Et c'est là toute la force et la
subtilité du boycott bienveillant.
J'aimerais vous donner
le témoignage de l'association Vida,
qui a eu gain de cause
sur notre plateforme :
« Le boycott bienveillant
est une révolution
dans notre rapport avec les marques,
et incarne un outil puissant
pour appuyer nos combats. »
Et les lobbys, les décideurs,
dans tout cela ?
Ils sont complètement court-circuités.
Le système est basé sur
la décentralisation du pouvoir.
Il ne s'appuie plus sur quelques personnes
avec qui les lobbys décident
de dîner, généralement,
mais sur des dizaines
de milliers d'acteurs.
Difficile de dîner avec 40 000 personnes,
ça fait un sacré budget !
(Rires)
Donc, maintenant que la solution
est quasiment évidente,
soyez le changement que vous
voulez voir dans le monde,
comme le disait un certain Gandhi.
Soyez consom'acteur.
Boycotter seul, c'est bien ;
ensemble, c'est le contre-pouvoir ;
et avec bienveillance,
c'est le changement.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)